اهلا بكم حدد رئيس مجلس النواب اللبناني
نبيه بري يوم الاربعاء المقبل موعدا
لانعقاد الجلسه الثانيه لاختيار رئيس جديد
للجمهوريه بعد تعذر اختياره في الجلسه
الاولى نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لننا شه في
محورين كيف بدات مواقف الاطراف اللبنانيه
بشان رئيس جديد من خلال الجلسه البرلمانيه
الاولى
لانتخابه وما فرص التوصل الى توافق وشيك
على الرئيس اللبناني في ضوء تباعد المواقف
القائمه
حاليا الى الاربعاء المقبل اذا رحل ملف
اختيار رئيس جديد في لبنان بعد ان سيطرت
الاوراق البيضاء على مشهد الجلسه الاولى
المخصصه لانتخابه وهي الجلسه التي ابانت
حسب مراقبين اختلاف مكونات الطيف السياسي
اللبناني بشان هويه الرئيس المقبل باكثر
مما ابانت توافقهم
بشانه لم تخرج الجوله الاولى من انتخابات
رئاسه الجمهوريه اللبنانيه من قبل
البرلمان عما كان متوقعا منها فالقوى
السياسيه فشلت في انتخاب رئيس جديد وسط
تراجع زحمه المرشحين بسبب غموض الوضع
الاقليمي المؤثر مباشره في الاستحقاقات
السياسيه لهذا البلد الهش تجاه ازمات
محيطه واذا كانت قوى الرابع عشر من اذار
قد بينت تماسكا في موقفها بدعم رئيس حزب
القوات اللبنانيه سمير جعجع الا ان قوى
الثامن من اذار وعددا من النواب المستقلين
سجلوا حضورهم باوراق بيضاء تعدت عدد
الاصوات التي نالها جعجع غير انهم لم
يتمكنوا من دفع شخصيه من اوسطهم للترشح
اما رئيس جبهه النضال الوطني فاعاد بدعمه
المرشح الثاني هنري حلو التلويح بورقته
الدائمه التي تقول انه صاحب المعادله
الصعبه والوزن التي ستحدد اسم الرئيس
المقبل رئيس البرلمان دعى لجلسه برلمانيه
الاسبوع المقبل لانتخاب الرئيس وهي دعوه
لا تنبئ بالضروره عن توافق حول الرئيس في
ذلك التاريخ بقدر ما انها دعوه اجرائيه
ستتكرر حسب الدستور اذا استم مرت حاله عدم
الوفاق الحاليه الى حين انتهاء ولايه
الرئيس اما حسم السباق نحو الرئاسه فسيحدث
وفق رؤيه الكثيرين هنا لاعبون اقليميين
ودوليون يشكل موضوع الرئاسه اللبنانيه
مجرد واحد من الملفات المطروحه قيد البحث
بينهم حقيقه تفتح الباب واسعا وفق اصحاب
وجهه النظر هذه لامكانيه حدوث فراغ رئاسي
كما حصل بعد انتهاء ولايه الرئيس السابق
ايميل
لحوت ويعتبر هؤلاء ان التقاطعات الاقليميه
التي ادت الى تشكيل حكومه متوازنه بين
القوى السياسيه اللبنانيه قد اخذت بعين
الاعتبار هذا السيناريو اذ ستقول للحكومه
كامله صلاحيات الرئيس اللبناني في حال
الفراغ حسب الدستور
اللبناني لكن المتفائلين من المحللين
يذهبون الى القول ان تفاهمات الاقليميه
التي جاءت بحكومه تمام سلام بعد 11 شهرا
من التفاوض تستطيع التوصل الى تسويه جديده
تؤدي حكما الى انتخاب رئيس من خارج القوى
السياسيه الحاليه كحل وسط يعمل على ابعاد
لبنان عن ارتدادات ازمات محيطه لكن اشاره
التوصل الى هذه النتيجه تحتاج الى زمن
اضافي قد يمتد لاشهر الصيف المقبل تحليلات
كثيره تطرح وسط الضبابيه السياسيه في
ملفات المنطقه ولبنان واحد منها لكن
المعطيات الحاليه تؤشر ال امر مؤكد وهو ان
انتخابات الرئاسه ست تجل حتى جلاء صوره
التفاهمات الاقليميه ايهاب العقدي الجزيره
بيروت معنا في هذه الحلقه من بيروت علي
حماده عضو الامانه العامه لقوى ال 14ب عشر
من اذار وانطوان نصر الله القيادي في
التيار الوطني الحر اهلا بضيفي هنا سيد
علي حماده هل عدد 48 صوت الذين تحصل عنهم
عليهم جعجع تعني ان هذا هو السقف الاعلى
وبالتالي انتهى امر جعجع بعد هذه
الجلسه بطبيعه الحال الجوله الاولى ل
الانتخابات اليوم انما عكست يعني جاءت
كمقدمه لهذه المرحله الانتخابيه او لهذه
الجولات الانتخابيه التي سوف
تتوالى المراد منها اولا ابراز وحده صفوف
قوى 14 اذار وايضا القول بان بان هناك
مرشحا معلنا ومرشحا واضحا وصريحا ومرشحا
لديه افكار ويعبر عن افكار 14 اذار اما
بالنسبه الى الاعداد هذه الاعداد ليست
مرشحه الى التراجع انما هي مرشحه الى
الزياده باعتبار بان هناك عددا من النواب
الذين كان يمكن ان يصوتوا الى جانب جعجع
بعضهم انضم الى الى كتله النائب ولي
الجمرات ويمكن ان يعودوا وينضم للتصويت
الى الى جانب جعجع في مرحله لاحقه كما ان
هناك عددا من النواب المبعدين قصرا عن
لبنان ومنهم الرئيس سعد الحريري والنائب
عقاب صقر وهناك نواب اخرون تغيبوا بداعي
السفر او بداعي المرض اذا لا جعجع ارقامه
مرشحه ربما الى الارتفاع وليس الى
الانخفاض ولازال من المبكر البحث في مرشح
اخر عن قوى 14 اذار ما زلنا في بدايه
الطريق نعم نعم في انتظار ان نعود لموضوع
كتله السيد وليد جنبلاط
سييد انطوان نصر
الله هذه الاوراق البيضاء المرشح الفائز
الاوراق البيضاء ان جاز التعبير ما
الرساله التي اريد الوصول اليها من خلال
هذا
التصويت يعني بروف اليوم انطلقت العمليه
الانتخابيه يعني اليوم كانت سفاره بدايه
عمليه انتخاب رئيس جديد ل للجمهوريه
اللبنانيه اي تعملنا هذا الاسلوب بالورقه
البيضاء لنقول بان اليوم مطلوب بعض
التفاهمات والكثير من الحوار من اجل
الوصول الى رئيس يستطيع ان يحكم يستطيع ان
يمارس سلطاته كامله نرفض بان يكون لدينا
رئيسا صوريا او
رئيسا يمنع من الحكم وهذا الامر يتطلب
الكثير من التشاور من المعروف ان التركيبه
اللبنانيه المعقده والدستور اللبناني فرض
نصابا معينا كما فرض عددا معين من النواب
من اجل انتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه وحتى اليوم
وحتى هذه اللحظه لم تتم هذه الامور لم
تتوضح كل هذه التفاهمات وكل هذه الامور من
هنا اردنا ان نوجه رساله بان يدنا ممدوده
الى الجميع اي الى جميع اللبنانيين من اجل
اصار رئيس لديه برنامج واضح لديه افكار
واضحه رئيس يلم البلد
اليوم في هذه الازمه
الاقليميه الكبيره التي تحدث في مختلف
البلدان العربيه رئيس لا يكون رئيس
تصادمي لا يجلب الحرب الى لبنان يرفض بان
يكون مطيه بيد احد من اجل القضاء على طرف
اساسي ومهم في لبنان وفي الوقت نفسه يرفض
ان تتكسر هيبه الدوله على ابواب اب عبده
نعم و ولكن اسمح لي سيد نصر الله اسمح لي
مثل ما تقدمت 14 اذار بالسيد سمير جعجع ما
الذي منع قوى الثامن من اذار من ان
تقدم ميشيل عون وهو المرشح ال الذي يبدو
الان ينتظر ما
سيجري العماد ميشيل عون لن يترشح بوجه احد
لن
يكون محرقه اي ب من اجل احد الماد عون اما
يتم
التوافق على اسمه كرئيس للجمهوريه لا يكفي
ان نترشح بل عنا ان نصل الى رئيس
الجمهوريه والعماد عون مع تاريخه السياسي
مع افكاره السياسيه مع نضالاته مع كل ما
يمثل من من الفئات اللبنانيه يرفض ان يكون
ليس بحاجه ليكون مرشحا من من هنا حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يترشح الاماد
عن يعني اسمح لي اسمح لي فقط ان اعود الى
السيد علي حماده لانه اشار الى الاصوات
التي كانت لكتله السيد وليد جمبلات
كيف قراتم هذه الكتله التي وقفت في الوسط
والتي يبدو انها ستكون محدده في
المستقبل يعني هذه لعبه او هذه مناوره
ذكيه من من قبل النائب وليد جنبلاط الذي
يعيد يعيد تركيب وضعه السياسي
باعتباره ميزانا بين القوى القوتين
الكبريين في لبنان قوى 14 ازار وقوى 8
ازار يعني هو حقيقه نجح بهذه المناوره
واستطاع ايضا ان يعيد يعيد لم شمل كتلته
الاساسيه كتله اللقاء الديمقراطي باعاده
انضمام النائب مروان حميدي ورفاقه ال الى
كتله وليد جلاط بهذا المعنى يريد النائب
وليد ج ملاط ان يقول بانه ايضا بانه عنصر
محدد في الانتخابات الرئاسيه حتى لو كانت
كتلته هي الكتله الاصغر ثانيا بانه يؤيد
وصول
مرشح وفاقي وليس مرشح تصادمي كان لقوى 8
اذار او لقوى 14 اذار وهذه وهذا خيار
سياسي من النائب وليد جملات وعليه سوف
يكون له دور كبير في تحديد
وجهه التصويت في المرحله المقبله او سيكون
له يد في فوز هذا المرشح او ذاك المرشح او
في
استبداد يعني استد باب حاله من ال من
التوافق السياسي حول مرشح وفاقي ومرشح
تسويه الان زلنا بعيدين عن التسويه بعيدين
عن التوافق اسمحلي في انتظار ذلك في
انتظار ذلك السيد انطوان نصر الله اشار
قبل قليل الى ان لم يقع ترشيح العماد
بلعون حتى لا يكون محرقه لاي كان في هذه
الحاله هل هل انتم ربما حرقتم بين
قوسين سمير جعجع بهذا الترشح الان في هذه
المرحله طبعا هناك ك فارق بين تكتيك
التكتيك السياسي يعني او التكتيك
الانتخابي بين بين قوى 14 اذار و القوى
الاخرى يعني الجنرال ميشيل عون يرى بانه
في التكتيك السياسي يؤثر ان يبقى بعيدا عن
عن عن المعركه الان لكي يطرح نفسه مرشحا
وفاقي ربما انما فيما يتعلق بجع جع اريد
من خلال ترشيح جعجع بان يكون ترشيحا واضحا
برنامجا واضحا رؤيه واضحه افكار واضحه ضوع
على ورق توزع اما الى الجميع لكي يقراها
ويعرفوا ويكونوا على بينه من هذا المرشح
اما فيما يتعلق بالجنرال ميشيل عون فطبعا
هو هو لديه خياره في التكتيك السياسي في
تكتيك الانتخابي وهذا امر طبعا يحق له
دستورا لا شيء يجبره على الترشح ولا شيء
يجبره على تقديم افكاره من جديد او او
التعبير عن مواقف
جديده وبناء عليه سوف ف يكون ال الاهم
ربما في المرحله المقبله ل قنوات الحوار
المفتوحه في الكواليس وقنوات التواصل
المفتوحه في الكواليس و وثم قنوات من
التواصل ما بين ما بين فريق الجنرال عون
وافقا اخرين في قوى 14 اذار و وعليه سوف
يتم تحديد الموقف من ترشيح الجنرال ميشيل
عون باعتباره وفقيه او باعتباره تصادميه
نم
ولكن موقف موقف
نعم نعم معذره موقف السيد وليد جمبلات كنت
عبرت عنه الان سيد علي حماده ولكن بالنسبه
لقوى الثامن من اذار سيد انطوان نصر الله
كيف نظرتم الى هذا التكتيك من قبل وليد
جنبلاط
يعني بالحقيقه وضعنا النائب وليد جنبلاط
بما سوف يقوم به بانه سوف
يرشح النائب هور حلو لرئيس الجمهوريه كما
قلت ما جرى اليوم هو بدايه ال العمليه
الانتخابيه وليس انتهائها الكل يوم يحاول
ان يقوم بمناورات ان لا لا يريد احد ان
يسلم كل جميع اوراقه كما نقول اي والناب
جملات بما اقدم عليه اليوم اصبح رقما في
في المعادله وهذا من حقه ولكن اتصور بان
الاتصالات معه لم تنقطع كما لم تنقطع مع
كل
ا يعني مع مختلف القوى اليوم التي يتمثل
منها التي تتمثل في البرلمان اللبناني من
اجل خروج خروج برئيس توافقي وكما نعلم
وهذا ليس امرا اي يحدث فقط في لبنان بان
الانتخابات لا تجرى داخل القاعه فقط وانما
عبر اتصالات وعبر لقاءات وعبر المشاورات
اي ينبثق عنها رئيسا جديدا وهذا ما سوف
تتكثف في وسوف يتكسف في الايام القادمه
اعتقد
بان ربما سوف يكون لدينا تطورات كل يوم كل
ساعه من اجل الوصول الى منع الفراغ والى
رئيس جديد للجمهوريه قبل الموعد الدستوري
المحدد ب 25 ايوم نعم الاتصالات التي تشير
اليها البعض يشير الى الاتصالات الوطنيه
الداخليه والبعض يركز اكثر على الاتصالات
الاقليميه والدوليه لهذا سنرى بعد الفاصل
الى اي مدى هناك امكانيه لانتخاب رئيس
جديد في لبنان قبل انتهاء المهله في ضوء
هذه الاتصالات وال المناورات ربما لنا
عوده بعد قليل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في
هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها فرص انتخاب
رئيس جديد للبنان ايه سيد علي حماده الان
ما الذي تتوقعونه بالنسبه للمرحله المقبله
لاختيار رئيس جديد
اولا مزيد
من من المشاورات ومن ومن المحادثات
في المباشره والثنائيه وحتى المتعدده
الجانب على الصعيد الداخلي هناك طبعا
مواكبه اقليميه نعرفها والجميع يعرفها
مواكبه ايضا دوليه لهذا الانتخاب لهذه
العمليه وهذا امر تقليدي في لبنان وليس
وليس مستجدا طبعا الامل هو ان تتوسع دائره
الدائره دائره اللبنه في لبنان لا ان
تتقلص لحساب ان يكون هناك اختيار لمرشح
لبناني صنع في لبنان باراده لبنانيه وبصوا
لبنانيه من دون ان تكون هناك مؤثرات
خارجيه لكن انا نعرف بان لبنان يتاثر
بالخارج هذا هذا من من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى طبعا هناك التكتيك الانتخابي هناك
المناورات الانتخابيه هناك محاوله حرق بعض
الاطراف هناك ايضا
مستجدات قد نشهدها يعني على صعيد سوف اعطي
مثالا على صعيد الجنرال ميشيل عون انه فتح
قنوات الحوار مع قوى 14 اذار مع قوى وازنه
في في في 14 اذار هناك كلام سياسي عميق
يتم التحاور حوله هناك مواقف ربما قد تكون
قوى 14 اذار المعنيه في انتظار ان يتخذها
الجنرال ميشيل عون لكي لكي يتم تحديده او
تصنيفه من قبل قوى 14 باذار بانه هو مرشح
وفا في هذه الحاله سيد حماده في هذه
الحاله هل يعني عفوا في هذه الحاله هل هل
قوى ال 14ب عشر من اذار مستعده لتنازل عن
عن مرشحها سمير جعجع اذا ما ابدى ميشيل
عون
من علامات واعده ومطمئنه كمرشح
توافقي لست في هذه اللحظه بقادر ان اعطي
جوابا حاسما حوض هذا الموضوع حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك مرشح هو الدكتور سمير جعجع
وهو مرشح قوى 14 اذار هناك توافق حوله
وحتى وحتى اشعار اخر هو المرشح نعم
الجنرال ميشيل عون ابلغ رسائل الى قوى 14
اذار الاساسيه والوازع وحتى الى النائب
وليد جملات بانه مرشح توافقي وبانه لن
يكون مرشحا عن 8 اذار وبانه سوف يحاول ان
يكون رئيسا لكل اللبنانيين وان يمسك يمسك
العصى في الوسط لكن طبعا هذا هذه هذه هذه
مشاورات وهذه افكار تم تداولها وقد ابلغت
لكن هناك هناك هناك اختبار لهذه لهذا
الكلام وهناك كلام اخر يتعلق بمدى قدره
الجنرال ميشل عون بان ينتقل من تحالفه مع
قوه ميني ازار الى الوسط وان لا يكون
متحالف مع يعني بعد اذنك ل نسال انطوان
نصر الله عن ميشيل عون فقد يكون هو الانسب
ان يتحدث عن عن تكتيك ميشيل عون المواكبه
الاقليميه والدوليه التي اشار اليها قبل
قليل السيد علي حماده سيد نصر الله هل
تجعل من شخصيه مثل ميشيل عون
ينتظر ان تتفق السعوديه مع ايران ان تتفق
واشنطن مع موسكو ان تتفق طهران مع سوريا
او غيرها هل هل في وارد ان يكون ميشيل عون
في هذه الوضعيه وهو الذي طالما تحدث عن
القرار المستقل والبعد والبعد عن
التجاذبات
الاقليميه العماد ميشيل عون يراهن على
الداخل اللبناني من هنا كما قال الاستاذ
علي حميده اي
يعني اجرى مشاورات مع كل الافرقاء ويجي
مشاورات دائما مع كل الافرقاء من اجل
الوصول الى لبنن
الاستحقاق وانما ونحن نعيش في لبنان وندرك
بان هذا لهذا الاستحقاق يعني وجه داخلي
ووجه خارجي او تاثير داخلي وتاثير خارجي
او فيتو داخلي وفيتو خارجي من هنا يعني
علينا ان نواكب
هذه المباحثات الداخليه مع الانتباه الى
ما ما يحدث في المنطقه وكما قلنا سابقا
بان المنطقه اليوم تشهد تغيرات تشهد
تبدلات تشهد تطورات تشهد انتخابات في في
في اكثر من
دوله ذكر هذه الانتخابات اسمح لي سيد نصر
الله هل هل هل دقيق الحديث عن انه جزء من
الترتيبات الخاصه بانتخاب رئيس جديد
للبنان انتظار انتخابات سوريا انتظار حتى
انتخابات العراق هل هل وصلت الامور الى
الى هذا الحد في لبنان
الان لا يعني لا يعني انا لا اريد ان اربط
الانتخابات في لبنان مع اي انتخابات
خارجيه وانما اليوم لبنان لم يعد او لم
يعد
هو الملف الاساسي لدى الدول الكبرى كل
الملف الاساسي اليوم هو استقرار لبنان
يعني وال طمانت لبنانيين بان لا حرب في
لبنان من هنا اتصور بان هذه الدول المؤثره
سواء كانت اقليميه او
عالميه تهتم اكثر بالانتخابات كما قلت في
في العراق او ربما في سوريا في مصر لديها
اهتمامات اخرى اتصور بان لبنان ياتي في
الدرجه الثانيه وهذا امر جيد وامر ايجابي
للبنانيين لكي يستطيعوا ان ان يكبروا
المساحات مساحات الالتقاء فيما بينهم ولكن
كما قلت ان الوجه الاقليمي الدولي سوف
يؤثر على بعض القوى من هنا من هنا يعني لا
اتصور ان هناك انتخابات الاربعاء القادم
يعني نكون واهمين اذا قلنا بان سوف يكون
لدينا رئيسا جديدا الاربعاء القادم الا
اذا ح هنا الاشكال سيد نصر الله هنا
الاشكال الخوف وهنا اسال السيد علي حماده
الخوف ان لجلسه الاربعاء المقبل ولا
الجلسه التي تليها ستحسم الامور وستظل
المساله مفتوحه الى حين التوافق الداخلي
او حتى الخارجي قبل الداخلي او الداخلي
بناء على الخارجي في هذه في هذه الصوره هل
يخشى ان نصل الى الفراغ او ان يكون الفراغ
هو احد المقالات المحتمله او حتى المرجحه
سيد
حماده
الفراغ احتمال احتمال وارد وهذا ليس بجديد
على الحياه السياسيه اللبنانيه وهذا مؤسف
طبعا ان يكون احتمال الفراغ واردا انما في
تقديري وانا انتمي الى الى طيف المتفائلين
ب
احتمالات اجراء هذه الانتخابات واتمام هذا
الاستحقاق ضمن المواعيد
الدستوريه هناك هناك اراده داخليه واضحه
للتهدئه وللعب من التهدئه الى تسويه معينه
تهدئ من الوضع اللبناني و وتهد وتعطي م
مساحه من الاستقرار الداخلي الرئاسه يمكن
ان تساهم في ذلك او اتمام استحقاق الرئاسي
يمكن ان يساهم في ذلك طبعا لازلنا في
بدايه المشوار يمكن ان يكون هناك اكثر من
جوله انما لا ليس مستبعدا ان ان يتم
الاستحقاق الرئاسي ضمن المواعيد الرسميه
اي قبل الخ من ايار ان الفراغ ليس قدرا في
لبنان كما يعتقد البعض نعم اذا لم يكن
الفراغ قدرا سيد انطوان نصر الله هل من
الوارد ضمن السيناريوهات التمديد لميشيل
سليمان باي حال من الاحوال اذا الامور
سارت بطريقه غير مرضيه لكل
الاطراف اعتقد بان التمديد اصبح ورائنا اي
واعتقد بان سوف يكون لدينا رئيسا جديدا
قبل الخ من ايار اي يعني لقد احسن الرئيس
بري بدعوته لجلسه اليوم وكما في جلسه
الاسبوع القادم
اي كل هذه الامور سوف ت ت تسرع بايجاد
المخارج من اجل انتخاب رئيس جديد اما
التمديد فاعتقد بان لا احد في لبنان حتى
الرئيس الحالي يقول بانه لا يريد التمديد
وبالتالي لا تمديد اليوم في لبنان اي
وربما تشكيل الحكومه وفق لما تشكلت عليه
من خوف الفراغ وبالتالي من خو اي من اجل
تامين استمراريه الحكم في لبنان في حال لا
سمح الله وقوع الفراغ الذي انا حتى هذه
اللحظات استبعده واقول بانه سوف يكون
لدينا رئيسا جديدا قبل ال 25 نعم هل هل هل
سؤال اخير هل التوافق سيد نصر الله بين
الرياض وطهران مع وصول الملف النووي
الايراني الى مالات مطمئنه قد يدفع باتجاه
حسب موضوع الرئاسه في
لبنان يعني هو من العوامل المهمه في اي
استقرار البلد وفي دفع المؤسسات اي للعمل
من ضمن
ال الاطر الدستوريه وانما ليس عاملا
وحيدا هناك كما قلنا التاثيرات الداخليه
وهناك بعض التاثيرات الخارجيه الاخرى ولكن
اتصور يعني اعتقد نم بان ايران والسعوديه
وكما كل الدول العربيه والاجنبيه تريد
الخير لهذا الوطن وكما نحن نريد الخير لها
اظن باننا سووف لذلك انا اصر بان سوف يكون
لدينا رئيسا جديدا قبل 25 م نعم في كلمتين
سيد علي حماده حول نفس
النقطه تماما انا اعتقد بانه هناك توافقات
وتفاهمات
اقليميه برزت وتجلت من خلال المساعده او
خلال مواكبه في تشكيل الحكومه الحاليه في
لبنان وهي حكومه
ائتلافيه يمكن ان تمتد وان تتوسع لتشمل
حمايه للاستحقاق الرئاسي
بما بما يكون ايجابيا وبما يكون عنصرا
للتهدئه وعبو نحو تسويه في لبنان شكرا لك
سيد علي حماده عضو الامانه العامه لقوى ال
14ب عشر من اذار شكرا للسيد انطوان نصر
الله القيادي في التيار الوطني
الحر في امان الله